what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I am here doing an
interview for a movie that I can call my
favorite of Sundance 2023 Gael
congratulations on Cassandra I'm so
happy that it's being so warmly and
enthusiastically embraced here but I
can't wait for everybody out there to
get to experience oh thank you thank you
so much I feel a bit like yeah it makes
me blush so thank you thank you so so
proud so only people at Sundance thus
far really know what this movie is about
so for our viewership who does not know
the story just yet can you give us a
brief description of your movie sure
it's um what is the story of Cassandra
who is the character that Saul Saul
armendariz wrestler from from El Paso
and from Juarez you know from El Paso
Texas Chihuahua Mexico uh he comes from
there and he created this character
called cassandro
um that uh belongs to the Exotic strand
of of uh there's many divisions in Lucha
Libre in Mexico wrestling can we just
say Lucha lyrics so as not to say
wrestling all the time okay okay
they have different uh let's say um
groups no or categories no so as the
rudos there's the technicals there's the
exoticos and uh he belonged to the
exoticus but him and his contemporaries
what they did was uh they subverted
completely the the way that uh Lucha
Libre Incorporated the exoticos and made
this exotic characters actually win you
know they started every wheel started to
support them you know we wanted them to
win and um and so this is the story of
uh of uh you know an interpretation of
the the struggle and the and the
victories of Cassandra so I was reading
Rogers director's statement on this and
he mentioned that you were the one and
only person he wanted to lead this film
did you have that confidence in yourself
when you first took the role and if you
didn't at what point in the process did
you find it Well I was I mean ever since
he told me about the film I I was about
the idea of Cassandra I I saw the photos
of Cassandra and wow yes I was like if
that would be great to dress up like
that and to uh and do the whole
wrestling and
um and I had never you know Lucha Libre
was not in my
what is it called the the
um like a list that you want to do in
life yes exactly that one yeah bucket
list no it wasn't in my bucket list like
it wasn't something I wanted to
to do and then when the opportunity came
it was like oh yes of course I I should
be yeah let's I have to I'm a Mexican
actor I have to do a Lucha Libre film
one day you know how come I'm not doing
this and and uh and so um so I I started
to sort of dream with the idea and get
excited by it and little by little it
started to take shape and you know and
become something that with with all good
things like you never remember the
initial point you know it's always like
difficult to say what was the initial
idea like you know it kind of uh built
up into something way uh very complex
and uh and yeah by the time we were
about to do the film uh it already felt
like I'm ready you know I wanna I wanna
do this and uh and experience this with
that in mind what you just described
going into filming what's a particular
thing about his real experience or or a
quality of his that you knew you wanted
to hold tied to and made sure we we saw
on screen but then also what is
something about him that you only
discovered during the production process
as you explored the role more okay so
um so started by by what I discovered
whilst doing it and and uh I mean this
is something that maybe on the outside
it I already realized it was going to be
complicated or difficult which was the
wrestling basically Lucha Libre is a is
an incredibly hard sport but once you
start doing it you just don't realize
how really hard it is how almost
monumentally hard it is like it's it's
one of the most uh
oh man I cannot even put adjectives to
it because it's just it's it's Lucha
Libre it's like mythological wrestling
you know it's fighting against
superheroes and images and kind of
because also it is a a performative
sport as well so you have to to embody
the character you know and you have to
play with the audience and you have to
so it was incredibly tiring and um and
film doesn't respect the the the organic
timing of uh of of you know biological
timing of cells like it's it's just so
tiring the the whole shooting period of
like 12 hours a day of you know doing
the wrestling it was like it was really
hard even for the wrestlers was really
hard they were like oh man making films
is a little bit boring you know and yeah
it can be it can be tiring and boring
sometimes
um but um but then it's great when you
watch them
um so that was that was something that I
discovered
truly in my in my in my body like uh
whilst doing the film and to incorporate
that it's like a kind of the more a very
stylized way of of
interpreting or acting you know like you
have to fight against being incredibly
tired
um and uh and one of the things that I
that I uh felt was uh you know special
uh but at the same time I didn't want to
put a a name to it I just wanted to to
to sort of gravitate or or yeah or
permeate the the the the the essential
archetype of cassandro's character that
is so joyful you know his joy and that's
why he became also uh very very famous
and Transcendent in the Lucha Libre
world because he uh it was a character
that was having fun and I was enjoying
and there was a interacting uh you know
almost like uh almost like in the drag
show you know like with the audience you
know and kind of just making everything
lighter and happy and and at the same
time yeah kind of uh breaking down
taboos you know like realizing that I
mean taboos are are not that big of a
deal once you break them you know they
make a beautiful sound when you break
them but afterwards it's like uh like
this is not a big of a deal nobody cared
you know every society was also kind of
evolving and uh and so yeah that that
can that Joy was something that wanted
to um to incorporate great success in
that department the the joyful Spirit of
this movie is infectious and it it
basically sends you out the door with
with a full heart feeling very energized
and also inspired that no matter what
you're experiencing you can do anything
yeah exactly exactly and also the fact
that I mean what I like a lot as an
audience you know or
fascinated by the the thesis of the film
in a way is that
in order to become yourself you have to
play someone else
you know and you have to to play a
character you know you have to because
who we are is who we wish we are also so
uh so I I mean for example with uh I
always said this uh in um when talking
about uh this series called Mozart in
the jungle you know the I used to play
this character called Rodrigo and I miss
him so badly because he was he's the
person I want to be you know like he's
the he would be my my uh
my sort of my
therapy for that year you know like two
months of thinking out loud no filter
saying what I think I want to be that
way of course I can't but I I would have
loved you know so so uh so that that's
the joy of acting and interpretation to
play other people to play other or
someone you wish you were you know I
love that thought so much you brought up
the athleticism of it all I assume you
went through a good deal of training to
prepare for this was there any
particular you know like a technique or
a specific hold or anything about the
sport that you found most difficult to
be able to pull off yeah well um I was
at the beginning with the whole physical
training I was really happy everything
heard and but I was feeling stronger you
know and I was eating everything as well
because uh uh to you know to have a
Lucha Libre you know worry it's not it
doesn't have to be like a macrobiotic
sort of you know chiseled but no it can
be like it can be a little bit you know
full of full of energy no and and so
that was very nice the beginning and
then
one started to do the the Lucha training
properly he started to to realize okay
this is I mean every every little
centimeter of my body was just hurting
and uh and in such pain you know the
pain that I couldn't even describe you
know it was like very internal and um
and I mean I said last night but I mean
amongst the many things that we used to
do it was this I mean that incorporates
the the Lucha training is like learning
how to fall no so uh so half of the of
the training is just learning how to
fall so you have to fall many many times
and do it properly you know in order not
to hurt yourself and of course the first
time you do it you're hurting all the
time and then as the more time it
doesn't you know you're not hurting that
much but you have to make a big sound as
well of falling that so it is it is uh
it is like going back to to Childhood
you know it is such a great sport that
is it's exactly what we used to do when
we were kids you know like uh wrestling
and then falling ah you know think about
the sound all the like the sound when
you hit the ring and the sound when like
they do slaps too yeah it's just like it
reverberates through my body to the
point that I feel like I could feel it
yeah and you really you really hurt
yourself so I think that was the the
most difficult thing was
wrestler in this sense you know because
I I I I mean there's a whole thing of
the professionalism that I never
experienced but uh
Santo when we were doing the the
wrestling match together uh he he told
me like I'm gonna show you like old
man's techniques you know he's like what
do you mean okay come so he would do the
so normally you know in the Chokehold
you would do this you know whatever you
know and you would do this that but then
with a with a little knuckle he would
put like
some kind of pressure here you know and
it would hurt
so much you know and and so everything
there's a point where he grabs my leg
and does like a kind of a it's just this
kind of
Chinese acupuncture points you know that
just hurt like completely the you know
yeah disintegrate you and uh and that's
something that that real wrestlers do
you know they know these little points
and so sometimes you would see like it's
just uh you know they're just holding
each other but they are actually you
know hurting themselves like and he's
very strong and he's very hard I mean
he's amazing he he helped us out a lot
as well yeah who had a sense of that
sport never ceases to amaze me I have to
let you go soon I could talk about
Cassandra all day long I have to squeeze
in one future question yes you probably
know that where this is going because I
told you I'm a big fan of horror I love
werewolf by night and I love the idea of
Marvel embracing horror more
I don't know I'm sure you can't tell us
anything about the continuation of that
character in the franchise but I was
curious about your opinion on
maintaining that tone and that style and
that grasp on that genre but if he were
to move into another corner of that
franchise do you think there's a way to
continue the character but still
maintain what makes werewolf finite so
unique oh cool I thought that you were
gonna for a moment I thought that you
were going to mention how Cassandra is
going to incorporate into the horror
world of Marvel and I would have been
like what yeah I mean I'd be fine with
that too yeah let's bring it on exactly
yeah of course I would be delighted
because also it was just a little tease
what I what we got you know and what I
experienced by by playing this character
in werewolf finite I loved it I I and
and the people that were there you know
with Laura Donnelly I mean it was
fantastic to work with her because she's
a very strong die die hard horror movie
fan you know and uh and it was fantastic
to play that and yes I hope that we can
do that in in different ways shapes and
forms and that uh and who knows where
it's going to go right I have no idea
but I'm really I'm I'm I want to be part
of that and uh and I really love the the
how it came out uh yeah I'm very pleased
I love horror movies as well I'm not a
big fan because I get really scared
um but uh but I like them a lot I I
think it's the most uh yeah it is like
the one of the the it is the genre that
encomp that encompasses the best aspects
of filmmaking you know it is like Opera
in a way I love it I love all film
horror is my number one genre so I like
that you say that I'll end with this you
know what's right next door to Marvel
Star Wars oh yeah I wouldn't mind a
world where maybe you appear in a future
season of Andor that would be fine that
would be that would be really fun but uh
but uh they're in the Galaxy very far
away and it's very difficult to find
them so yeah Diego just told me that the
important thing about that series is to
not make it feel like a galaxy far away
and make it feel very grounded and real
so I think it's closer to all of us he's
trying to get close to yeah he's trying
to make me I think he's carving a path
for you to jump over there whenever
you're exactly I'm always rooting for it
Cassandra is a very special film you
should all be very proud and I meant
what I said it's my favorite of the
festival and I can't wait for everyone
out there to experience it to everybody
watching this keep an eye out for the
movie and stay tuned for more from
Sundance 2023